today there's a bloomberg news piece out
they surveyed a large number of Kannamma
still our gist economic threats to Great
Britain and number one and number two
we're brexit and number three four five
and so they the economists sometimes get
something right so tell us your thoughts
about this well look it's obviously very
very serious that you've got a
significant section in the governing
party of the UK in the Conservative
Party who have defined their politics in
opposition to the European Union they
forced the Prime Minister to pledge a
referendum he's now trying to negotiate
his way through it and he wants to have
it sooner rather than later but
obviously with the the situation in
wider Europe low growth refugee crisis
Greek crisis continuing it's not the
best circumstances I think it is the
risk I wouldn't say it's a likelihood
that Britain will fall out but there's a
significant risk of an accident so if I
was an economist answering your poll I'd
say you've got to take this seriously as
the biggest short to medium-term risk to
UK prosperity then if you're taking it
seriously what action do you take if
you're an investor or if you're an
economist when you say take it seriously
what does that actually mean what does
it entail
I think the first thing is that you've
got to advise your own supervisors your
own authorities that this is something
that needs to be planned for you need to
hedge but secondly I would say business
needs to speak out globalization has
been good for Britain it's been good for
Europe it's been part of an
extraordinary wave of prosperity and
innovation the voice of business should
be heard in the debate I mean I'm based
in New York now running an NGO so I'm
out of politics I was farming it's
decided it's not my game anymore
but as I'm still a British citizen I'll
be a voter in the Europe referendum I
know where I want the rest of my life my
kids lives to be and that's as part of
Europe not somehow declaring
independence I mean yes the emotional
question it's easy from New York and the
share of the Statue of Liberty
how many Syrians should make the
pilgrimage to Canterbury I mean within
the scope and scale of what we're
dealing with how do you perceive X
number of people and families and
children and school expenses going to a
small shop like canna Berg I think the
most important is that the most
vulnerable get housed in the rich
countries the UN says the 10% most
vulnerable Syrian refugees so that'll be
four hundred thousand of the form
that would be widows and orphans
essentially they should be rehoused are
relocated into the richer countries now
the US has taken 2,200 Syrians in the
last four years you know the debate
about security it's harder to get into
the u.s. as a refugee than any other
ways so I would say okay let me give you
the answer I represented a constituency
more or less the size of Canterbury okay
there's a constituency of 65,000 people
in the UK and at the moment if the UK
took 25,000 people a year that would be
about 40 per constituency great now I'm
and I no one's going to tell me that
forty people would have overwhelmed my
constituency
Justin Trudeau in Canada 25,000 the u.s.
if it was taking its share it was
playing the leadership role if it was
living up to the Statue of Liberty would
be taking about a hundred thousand this
is so important we've got to repair it
yes given the scale that you see in the
experts see forty people end up in the
emotion of every single town in villages
city 40 should it but obviously bigger I
mean I was replicants is our districts
are smaller than yours there's 65,000
people but the the thing is that the 10%
was runnable those who've lost
everything they've lost family members
they need a new start and they're not
even I'm going to find it amidst the
chaos that exists in too many parts of
the Middle East and I think there's a
really important point here that people
don't understand it's not just the
numbers and the lives that are changed
at the moment our allies in the Middle
East feel they're on their own then that
we're not standing with them and so
symbolically as well as in substantive
terms refugee resettlement is part of
our bargain yet this has become
conflated in the u.s. political arena
with terrorism and national security in
a very serious and very you know sort of
hyperbolic way is that a solvable
problem in an election year well I I
hope so because I have great faith in
the American in in democracy in the
American system now the truth is that
the lie about the Syrian passport in the
Paris attacks caused enormous damage to
this debate it gave an excuse for people
to say a refugee equals a terrorist the
people who are fleeing as refugees are
running away from terror not trying to
cause terror they are the most heavily
vetted entrance into the
u.s. you have to prove that you're
entitled to become a refugee not that
you have an automatic riot and 750,000
people have come to the US since 9/11
through the refugee resettlement program
and this is a proven American success
story that it would be a tragedy if you
step back from so given the size of
these problems whether it's refugees
whether it's brexit the other things you
were a major leader in the United
Kingdom at some point you must think
maybe I should go back and it helped
lead us out of this it's very nice of
you to say that in the end it's the
voters who choose and we lost the
election in twenty mile government I was
part of lost the election in 2010 so
look the the job I'm doing the man I've
been in New York for two years now
running an NGO that was founded by
Einstein in New York in 1933 to help
rescue people from around the world we
now work 700 million dollar organization
in 30 countries I feel I'm doing good
not according to the statistics but
according to the individuals and that's
the way I think I'm playing our role
about that but do you rule out the
possibility of going back and standing
again III never really know rule out
because you know people say to me that
the kids college kids come and say well
what should I do in my life and either
20 years I say look I'm 50 and I haven't
figured it out so what you're like
should they build the third runway at
Heathrow yeah we're lucky that David is
in New York doing the work he is David
Mel man thank you for joining us my mom